I've had the real fortune
of working at Scripps Research
for the last 17 years.
It's the largest nonprofit biomedical
institution in the country.
And I've watched some of my colleagues,
who have spent two to three years
to define the crystal
3-D structure of a protein.
Well, now that can be done
in two or three minutes.
And that's because
of the work of AlphaFold,
which is a derivative of DeepMind,
Demis Hassabis and John Jumper,
recognized by the American
Nobel Prize in September.
What's interesting, this work,
which is taking the amino acid
sequence in one dimension
and predicting the three-dimensional
protein at atomic level,
[has] now inspired many other of these
protein structure prediction models,
as well as RNA and antibodies,
and even being able to pick up
all the missense mutations in the genome,
and even being able
to come up wit proteins
that have never been invented before,
that don't exist in nature.
Now, the only thing I think about this
is it was a transformer model,
we'll talk about that in a moment,
in this award, since Demis and John
and their team of 30 scientists
don't understand how
the transformer model works,
shouldn't the AI get an asterisk
as part of that award?
I'm going to switch from life science,
which has been the singular biggest
contribution just reviewed,
to medicine.
And in the medical community,
the thing that we don't talk much about
are diagnostic medical errors.
And according to the National
Academy of Medicine,
all of us will experience
at least one in our lifetime.
And we know from a recent
Johns Hopkins study
that these errors have led
to 800,000 Americans dead
or seriously disabled each year.
So this is a big problem.
And the question is, can AI help us?
And you keep hearing
about the term “precision medicine.”
Well, if you keep making the same mistake
over and over again, that's very precise.
(Laughter)
We don't need that,
we need accuracy and precision medicine.
So can we get there?
Well, this is a picture of the retina.
And this was the first major hint,
training 100,000 images
with supervised learning.
Could the machine see things
that people couldn't see?
And so the question was,
to the retinal experts,
is this from a man or a woman?
And the chance of getting it
accurate was 50 percent.
(Laughter)
But the AI got it right, 97 percent.
So that training,
the features are not even fully defined
of how that was possible.
Well that gets then
to all of medical images.
This is just representative,
the chest X-ray.
And in fact with the chest X-ray,
the ability here for the AI to pick up,
the radiologists, expert radiologists
missing the nodule,
which turned out to be picked up
by the AI as cancerous,
and this is, of course,
representative of all of medical scans,
whether it’s CT scans, MRI, ultrasound.
That through supervised learning
of large, labeled, annotated data sets,
we can see AI do
at least as well, if not better,
than expert physicians.
And 21 randomized trials
of picking up polyps --
machine vision during
colonoscopy -- have all shown
that polyps are picked up better
with the aid of machine vision
than by the gastroenterologist alone,
especially as the day goes on,
later in the day, interestingly.
We don't know whether picking up
all these additional polyps
changes the natural history of cancers,
but it tells you about machine eyes,
the power of machine eyes.
Now that was interesting.
But now still with deep learning models,
not transformer models,
we've seen and learned that the ability
for computer vision to pick up things
that human eyes can't see
is quite remarkable.
Here's the retina.
Picking up the control of diabetes
and blood pressure.
Kidney disease.
Liver and gallbladder disease.
The heart calcium score,
which you would normally get
through a scan of the heart.
Alzheimer's disease before any
clinical symptoms have been manifest.
Predicting heart attacks and strokes.
Hyperlipidemia.
And seven years before
any symptoms of Parkinson's disease,
to pick that up.
Now this is interesting
because in the future,
we'll be taking pictures
of our retina at checkups.
This is the gateway to almost
every system in the body.
It's really striking.
And we'll come back to this
because each one of these studies
was done with tens or hundreds [of]
thousands of images
with supervised learning,
and they’re all separate studies
by different investigators.
Now, as a cardiologist,
I love to read cardiograms.
I've been doing it for over 30 years.
But I couldn't see these things.
Like, the age and the sex of the patient,
or the ejection fraction of the heart,
making difficult diagnoses
that are frequently missed.
The anemia of the patient, that is,
the hemoglobin to the decimal point.
Predicting whether a person,
who's never had
atrial fibrillation or stroke
from the ECG,
whether that's going to likely occur.
Diabetes, a diagnosis of diabetes
and prediabetes, from the cardiogram.
The filling pressure of the heart.
Hypothyroidism
and kidney disease.
Imagine getting an electrocardiogram
to tell you about all these other things,
not really so much about the heart.
Then there's the chest X-ray.
Who would have guessed
that we could accurately determine
the race of the patient,
no less the ethical implications of that,
from a chest X-ray through machine eyes?
And interestingly, picking up
the diagnosis of diabetes,
as well as how well
the diabetes is controlled,
through the chest X-ray.
And of course, so many different
parameters about the heart,
which we could never,
radiologists or cardiologists,
could never be able to come up
with what machine vision can do.
Pathologists often argue about a slide,
about what does it really show?
But with this ability of machine eyes,
the driver genomic mutations
of the cancer can be defined,
no less the structural
copy number variants
that are accounting
or present in that tumor.
Also, where is that tumor coming from?
For many patients, we don’t know.
But it can be determined through AI.
And also the prognosis of the patient,
just from the slide,
by all of the training.
Again, this is all just
convolutional neural networks,
not transformer models.
So when we go from the deep neural
networks to transformer models,
this classic pre-print,
one of the most cited pre-prints ever,
"Attention is All You Need,"
the ability to now be able
to look at many more items,
whether it be language or images,
and be able to put this in context,
setting up a transformational
progress in many fields.
The prototype is,
the outgrowth of this is GPT-4.
With over a trillion connections.
Our human brain has 100 trillion
connections or parameters.
But one trillion,
just think of all
the information, knowledge,
that's packed into those one trillion.
And interestingly, this is now multimodal
with language, with images,
with speech.
And it involves a massive amount
of graphic processing units.
And it's with self-supervised learning,
which is a big bottleneck in medicine
because we can't get experts
to label images.
This can be done
with self-supervised learning.
So what does this set up in medicine?
It sets up, for example,
keyboard liberation.
The one thing that both
doctors, clinicians
and patients would like to see.
Everyone hates being
data clerks as clinicians,
and patients would like
to see their doctor
when they finally have the visit
they've waited for a long time.
So the ability to change
the face-to-face contact
is just one step along the way.
By having the liberation from
keyboards with synthetic notes
that are driven,
derived from the conversation,
and then all the downstream normal
data clerk functions that are done,
often off-hours.
Now we're seeing in health systems
across the United States
where people, physicians
are saving many hours of time
and heading towards ultimately
keyboard liberation.
We recently published, with the group
at Moorfields Eye Institute,
led by Pearse Keane,
the first foundation model
in medicine from the retina.
And remember those eight different things
that were all done by separate studies?
This was all done with one model.
This is with 1.6 million retinal images
predicting all these different
outcome likelihoods.
And this is all open-source,
which is of course really important
that others can build on these models.
Now I just want to review a couple
of really interesting patients.
Andrew, who is now six years old.
He had three years of relentlessly
increasing pain, arrested growth.
His gait suffered with a dragging
of his left foot,
he had severe headaches.
He went to 17 doctors over three years.
His mother then entered all
his symptoms into ChatGPT.
It made the diagnosis
of occulta spina bifida,
which meant he had a tethered spinal cord
that was missed by all 17 doctors
over three years.
He had surgery to release the cord.
He's now perfectly healthy.
(Applause)
This is a patient that was sent to me,
who was suffering with,
she was told, long COVID.
She saw many different
physicians, neurologists,
and her sister entered all her symptoms
after getting nowhere,
no treatment for long COVID,
there is no treatment validated,
and her sister put all
her symptoms into ChatGPT.
It found out it actually
was not long COVID,
she had limbic encephalitis,
which is treatable.
She was treated, and now
she's doing extremely well.
But these are not just anecdotes anymore.
70 very difficult cases
that are the clinical
pathologic conferences
at the New England Journal of Medicine
were compared to GPT-4,
and the chatbot did as well
or better than the expert
master clinicians
in making the diagnosis.
So I just want to close
with a recent conversation with my fellow.
Medicine is still an apprenticeship,
and Andrew Cho is 30 years old,
in his second year
of cardiology fellowship.
We see all patients
together in the clinic.
And at the end of clinic the other day,
I sat down and said to him,
"Andrew, you are so lucky.
You're going to be practicing medicine
in an era of keyboard liberation.
You're going to be
connecting with patients
the way we haven't done for decades."
That is the ability to have the note
and the work from the conversation
to derive things like pre-authorization,
billing, prescriptions,
future appointments --
all the things that we do,
including nudges to the patient.
For example, did you get
your blood pressure checks
and what did they show
and all that coming back to you.
But much more than that,
to help with making diagnoses.
And the gift of time
that having all the data of a patient
that's all teed up before
even seeing the patient.
And all this support changes the future
of the patient-doctor relationship,
bringing in the gift of time.
So this is really exciting.
I said to Andrew, everything
has to be validated, of course,
that the benefit greatly
outweighs any risk.
But it is really a remarkable time
for the future of health care,
it's so damn exciting.
Thank you.
(Applause)